all right underwater so for me one of my
personal fears is dark water yeah so
this film was like horrifying for me to
watch but it was so good do you have any
phobias of water maybe tight spaces both
of those things yeah yeah I'm not like
the strongest swimmer not because I'm
like not good at swimming per se I'm
just scared of water yeah really and
super claustrophobic so yeah I think I
only ever really want to make a movie if
there's something about it that is like
unsurmountable like you don't I mean
like it just sort of seems like how am I
ever gonna get through that yeah this
one who checked a few boxes yeah this
suits looked uncomfortable like clásico
but did you feel that way while making
it yeah it really was
it was not good the suits like weighed
basically our own body weight depending
on how big you were so the guys suits
were heavier but kind of the same
experience for all of us we were
dragging ourselves around basically yeah
and the movie starts off in the first 5
minutes like with a huge explosion so
you don't know any of the characters
very well you find everyone in the midst
of crisis yeah so a huge thing about the
movie was actually just the physical
sensation of feeling so sort of closed
off from your facets and kind of like
helpless and at odds with your
environment and we were like fully and
not the whole time because we couldn't
move we couldn't talk to each other we
couldn't move like it was like we were
really stifled mm-hmm so you're being
honored with actress of the decade and
from what we've seen of you you don't
seem like someone that likes attention
that much so how are you gonna deal with
being honored for something like this
oh um well I'm I'm making a movie and so
I don't actually really I don't I'm
gonna deal with that here right after we
finished these interviews I'm gonna
record an incredibly grateful message
that inserts me into that scenario
without me actually having to be there
which is rad and it's funny that they're
also honoring Adam driver who also
Disney want to see him zone work so it's
like you just don't even want to really
take on that kind of appreciation I feel
like or that attention so to speak was
there a movie growing up that just
horrified you - jaws I think now it's
underwater but did you have one growing
up that just terrified you there was a
like there was like a really random
monster movie that I saw when I was
little that scared me so much and like
I'd like to see it again cuz you like it
was one of those things that you wonder
if it holds up and it scared me so badly
when I watched it my parents like went
to take out the trash and I like ran
outside as a little kid I remember my
parents being like go back inside like I
got in trouble and I was like you're
insane like I can't be alone like I
can't
yeah um Castle freak okay and this is
kind of a monster movie so maybe in
keeping with that that movie scared me a
lot and I loved it